the culture wars begun have they we're
gonna talk about the Emmys we'll talk
about whether CNN likes boobs yeah
really and we'll also talk about
President Trump golfing towards
Hillary's back or something and then
tweeting about it I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show so all the
things are stupid welcome back it's
Monday yeah everything is very stupid
this week and we will be talking about
the Emmys in a little while
but before we talk about the Emmys first
I want to talk about all things
political that are actually important or
quasi important for a couple of reasons
one is because the Emmys are less
important than what's actually going on
I'm gonna give you the entire narrative
and then also because if we show too
many clips of the Emmys then Facebook
gets mad at us so we'll be showing those
who these two look a bit later in the
show but first I want to say thank you
to my friends over a texture okay
texture is a fantastic app where you can
get basically subscriptions to 200-odd
magazines for now $6.99 a month normally
it's 999 a month right now if you
subscribe it's $6.99 a month I'm talking
magazines like people Esquire Time
Reader's Digest Nath National Geographic
Sports Illustrated Vanity Fair vogue
Fast Company Rolling Stone cosmopolitan
in stop basically you think of a
magazine and they will offer you a
subscription to it okay that's what the
app does they give you all of these
trusted sources for one low price plus
the back issues it makes it very very
easy texture is searchable so you can
mark what you like check out back issues
the bonus video content they even curate
articles and magazines just for you or
who or whomever you are giving texture
to this year okay it's texture calm
texture calm and right now they are
offering a 14-day free trial so you can
check out all of those magazines for
that one low price normally as I say
it's a $9.99 a month right now it's
$6.99 a month it's great for me because
I'm always on the road I don't want have
to schlep along a armful of magazines
instead you just get it right there on
your phone or on your iPad texture
offers that 14-day free trial when you
go to texture calm slash bun that's 14
days to try it for free texture calm
slash man and right now it's only
temporary $6.99 a month instead of $9.99
a month $6.99 a month so less than the
cost of a single magazine right not even
a subscription less than the cost of a
single man
you're getting like 200 magazines so
it's pretty awesome texture calm / been
if you're an information junkie it is
the best that there is texture calm /
better okay so as I say I could begin
with the Emmys but before I get to the
Emmys I really want to talk about why I
think President Trump won now what's
what's really interesting is when you
talk about why President Trump won I
know it's it's sort of an old topic but
there's a phrase that's used very
frequently you'll see a piece of news
and somebody will say that's why Trump
won and you'll see a piece of news and
so that's why Trump won you notice it's
never a piece of news that actually has
to do with politics as ever a news that
has to do with politics per se it's
always something that has to do with the
culture it's always a kindergarten
forces young kids to be to be confronted
with transgenderism or a baker is forced
to cater a same-sex wedding there's
always stuff like that this is why Trump
won or somebody gets mad at a
right-winger for some stupid reason they
decide to fire Brendan I ship Mozilla
Firefox and say ah that's why Trump won
it's never about the issues the reason I
say this and the reason I think this is
deeply important is because it's very
easy to get caught up in the idea the
president Trump won because of
particular political viewpoints I don't
think that's correct that's important
because right now President Trump is
obviously in the middle of a shift
toward the middle
he's obviously shifting his politics
from what people would consider the
normal hardline right the kind of Ann
Coulter populist right he's shifting
from there to many Democratic policies
and there are a lot of pundits people
like Ann who have been saying well he's
gonna lose his support base right this
is the perspective of Steve Danon as
well that he ran on all these populist
issues and that's why he won I don't
actually think that's why he won he'll
Ross dude hat during the election cycle
a guy who's sort of more mainstream
traditional conservative than then
Coulter Orban and he was saying the
whole time that Trump won because he
talked about issues nobody talked about
before tariffs and trade and higher
taxes and all this kind of stuff I
really don't think that's what it was I
think that a lot of the support for
President Trump was attitudinal I think
a lot of it was about attitude I think
most of it was about culture and that's
why the Emmys matter we'll get to the
Emmys in a little while here but that's
why the Emmys matter because if you
watch the Emmys the Emmys will drive
more votes into president Trump's column
than anything he does in terms of
straight policy this year or
next the culture war is what people are
hit with in the face every day they're
not hit with policy every day most of
the policies you live with are made at
the local and state level they're not
made at the federal level most of your
life probably did not change all that
much when President Obama was president
on a policy level it changed somewhat
rhyming our tax rates went up and down
if you're in a business you had to deal
with the Obamacare stick but if you're
just a normal employee of a company your
life probably probably did not change
radically thanks to President Obama or
thanks to george w bush or thanks to
Bill Clinton or thanks to Ronald Reagan
the fact is most be in our mass media
era what matters most is the culture war
everyone wants to focus in on the
political war what matters most of the
culture war and I'll show you why the
SIG's so right now
Tomica there again president Trump's in
the middle of a policy shift and the
shift is pretty thorough going Tom
cotton who's been an ally of the
president senator from Arkansas he was
ripping on president Trump's president
Trump's plans with regard to the DREAM
Act over the weekend now remember
President Trump campaigns on the idea
that everyone has to go we have laws
we're a country of laws this was his
shtick is what he's dead and now
President Trump says we're going to
reinsure intent to bomb is deferred
action on childhood arrivals we're gonna
legalize everybody between the ages of
16 and 31 by 2012 and who had arrived in
the country before 2007 and doesn't have
a criminal record we're gonna legalize
all those people were gonna make
Congress do it and we're not gonna stump
for a wall and we're not really gonna do
much about our border problem but we're
gonna give the Democrats what they want
so Tom cotton was on Meet the Press with
Chuck Todd he was basically saying this
is the worst amnesty ever it's the
biggest amnesty ever it's gonna be just
terrible give me a definition of amnesty
because it's in the eye of the beholder
it feels particularly when it comes to
uh it comes to this debate on the on the
right side of the spectrum here what is
your definition of amnesty well amnesty
is giving legal status to people who
came here illegally but the the core
debate is not over what easily this is
amnesty for daca well if you pass the
so-called DREAM Act it will be the
single biggest amnesty in the history of
the United States even bigger than the
1986 amnesty which Ronald Reagan said
was his biggest mistake in office but
the core debate here has never been
about legal status for these 700,000 or
so people it's been
we gonna control the negative
side-effects of that which is
undercutting American jobs in wages
my legislation the Rays Act would do
that and deterring more illegal
immigration I mean put yourself in the
shoes of a parent Canela see how many
votes do you think are actually
mobilized by this kind of policy the
answer is I don't think that many I
don't think that many hey this is why
Trump feels so free to move Clinton did
the same thing right on the left there
was this idea that Bill Clinton was some
great sort of leftist leader Bill
Clinton cut deals with a Republican
Congress on a regular basis they called
the triangulation triangulation just
means that he was gonna do popular stuff
with the opposite party and his own base
didn't care because again Bill Clinton
was a culture warrior and all that
matters is the culture war another
example of President Trump moving to the
left Heidi Heitkamp who's the senator
from North Dakota she's a Democrat she's
in serious trouble in her next Senate
race Oh Trump has been out there
campaigning with her saying she's a
wonderful woman Heidi Heitkamp right now
she's out there saying that she wants to
do an infrastructure deal with Trump
okay I can tell you that he think the
president realizes that the best policy
comes from bipartisan discussions and he
wanted to host one and tell us that he's
very interested in our input and so joe
Manchin and Joe Donnelly and myself were
invited to sit down with John soon from
South Dakota Orrin Hatch from Utah Ron
Johnson from Wisconsin and Pat Toomey
from Pennsylvania and really spend a lot
of time visiting about you know what our
expectations were for tax reform try and
figure out where the sweet spot is but
we also talked about the infrastructure
and being from New York from now he was
talking about this during the campaign
that we're gonna spend lots on
infrastructure but obviously this is not
typical mainstream conservatism we
complained when President Obama dumped a
trillion dollars are close to it in his
stupid stimulus package that didn't do
anything for the economy now Trump's
doing the same thing do you think it's
gonna lose him a lot of votes I don't
okay how about the Paris Accords right
this is a big win for conservatives the
idea that Trump was gonna pull out of
the global warming oriented Paris
Accords this was in an accord that
supposedly committed us to moving toward
a carbon
zero net carbon emissions economy Rex
Tillerson the Secretary of State now
he's walking it back he's saying well
Trump might actually stay in the Paris
Accords now again the right was
celebrating this do you think the
Trump's gonna lose a lot of votes
because of this but there's a chance
that if things get worked out both on
the voluntary side from the US the
voluntary restrictions for the US that
it could change but then also in China
there's a chance the US could stay in
the Accord is that right I think under
the right conditions the president said
he's open to finding those conditions
where we can remain engaged with others
on what we all agree is still a
challenging issue ok so again another
issue where President Trump is obviously
moving to the left is he's gonna lose
him
a lot of votes here's why I don't think
it's going to lose him a lot of votes I
don't think that it's gonna lose him a
lot of votes because the truth is most
people didn't vote for Trump thinking he
was an ideologue
it's amazing Democrats are finally now
becoming to come around on this they're
they're finally beginning to figure this
out Adam Schiff Democrat from California
he says just this that you know Trump's
only ideology is being pro Trump yeah
there were some of us who are saying
this during the entire campaign
Democrats though were saying that Trump
was Hitler right Trump was Hitlerian
it's that culture war that matters not
the policy work is what Schiff says
here's basically right Trump does not
have an ideology he's just gonna do
whatever he thinks is good for himself
well I didn't make me question that
because I think all of us recognize that
that outreach for what it is and that's
purely transactional purely something
that will come up from time to time when
the president decides it's in his
personal interest to work with Democrats
this is a president look who has no
ideology he's not conservative he's not
liberal the only consistent theme seems
to be he's Pro Trump he's for his own
person sometimes true but that doesn't
actually make much of a difference
because again the idea here is that in
the culture war you are pro Trump or
anti Trump again there's the political
side where Trump is all over the place
but nobody actually pays attention to
that what people pay attention to is the
narrative the media narrative the
cultural narrative does something Andrew
Breitbart from one of my mentors was
very big on this idea that the culture
was upstream of politics then what we
imbibe from the from the culture around
us is much more important than the
politics of a given situation and this
is particularly true of Trump again
Trump is currently governing like a
moderate Democrat
okay what he's done over the last couple
of weeks has been stuff that is straight
from the Democrat playbook it is not
from the conservative playbook but in a
cultural way Trump is offensive to the
left and the left is offensive to the
Trump people and therefore there is a
war going on even though he's now
currently governing with Nancy Pelosi
and Chuck Schumer pretty isn't amazing
something I'm gonna get to that culture
war in just a second and why I think the
President Trump this is one area where I
think Trump is quite astute I'm gonna
talk about that in just a second but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Zeile so I am very big
on the idea that you don't have to be
wealthy in order to feel wealthy in the
United States one of the ways that you
feel wealthy is by getting a massage
every so often and that's what Zeile is
there for okay instead of you having to
make a reservation at the spa and then
show up at some weird place with with
some weirdo staffing the front desk
instead is he'll make sure that a
licensed masseuse comes to your home
brings all the materials and gives you a
fantastic massage you can book a 5-star
top-quality massage at a time that works
for you in the most convenient place
your own home I've done in my house a
bunch of times we've had seal work on me
worked on my wife worked on my
mother-in-law worked on my father worked
on my mother what kind of my sister like
this is one of these these services that
really everyone in my family has used
because it is so incredibly convenient
they scream your ID they make sure that
all of their own employees are licensed
so you're not gonna get some kook coming
to your house these are all licensed
masseuses again make sure that you go
over to zeal comm right now if you go
over to Z EE L calm and use promo code
Bennett check out you got $25 off your
first massage by using that promo code
been at checkout right now if you sign
up for their massage membership you get
20% off all your massages plus a free
massage table and sheet set a 380 dollar
value yours free
there's no initiation fee to join the
membership just a terrific additional
savings on top of that $25 discount
you're gonna get when you use promo code
been again at z ee l comm z ee l comm
and make sure to click add promo code at
checkout to use my code Ben I get $25
off your first in-home on-demand massage
you can get these things on really short
notice you just decide that morning you
want a massage and they'll make sure
that it happens for you again this is
one of those things that just makes you
feel wealthy even if you don't have tons
of money sitting around ze al.com
use there's their iPhone or Android app
as well and use that promo code Bennet
check out get $25 off your first
in home massage and if you get that
massage membership 20% off everything
plus the free massage table and sheet
set okay so why doesn't any of this
matter why doesn't it matter that all of
the issues that Trump ran on and that
conservatives celebrate he seems to be
moving away from now he's moving away
from his hard stance on immigration and
Ann Coulter's going nuts he's moving
away from his hard stance on the Paris
Accords and some people on the right are
saying oh dude what the hell he's now
moving toward infrastructure which was a
populist Steve ban and talking point for
a long time why doesn't any of that seem
to matter
why is it that that why is it that his
shift on ideology doesn't seem to matter
even Democrats are recognizing that he
doesn't have ideology anymore why
doesn't any of that seem to matter and
the answer is because of the culture
wars the culture wars are all that
matter they're all that matter here is
why President Trump is going to continue
to maintain his base okay he tweeted
this out yesterday this is a gift or a
Jif I've still not decided how I wish to
pronounce that that word here he is okay
and it's a Jif of him hitting a golf
ball that hits Hillary Clinton in the
back and knocks her over right he
retweeted this yesterday from an account
called effed up mind except didn't say
after right and I'll acknowledge it's
pretty funny Jeff okay like we use this
a similar Jeff with regards to somebody
who dr. pepper balls right him hitting
the golf ball and then it hitting that
guy in the nads okay this I find
slightly less funny just be it's still a
little funny but the part that's the
part that's not so funny about it is
that the President of the United States
is the one who's actually retweeting it
okay it really is not particularly
appropriate for the President of the
United States to retweet things about
him physically assaulting a fellow
presidential candidate let alone a
female presidential candidate because
again the left is just going to cry
sexism but his base loves this okay so
long as Trump is willing to be
quote-unquote politically incorrect and
tweet this stuff then he's gonna love it
and the left's gonna hate it so he's
using the culture war in order to avoid
the political war okay in other words
this is WWE in WWE I haven't I can Sam
and WWE kind of serve and I know this
much you have the stock villains and you
have the stock heroes and they fight
each other and sometimes they switch
places and the villain becomes the hero
and the hero becomes the villain but
everybody is playing a particular kind
of role and in the end they go out back
and they drink with one another it's not
they actually hate each other it's all
it's all
did ok president Trump doesn't hate
Hillary Clinton she was at his wedding
if President Trump doesn't hate the left
he's making deals with them right now
but as part of the culture war he does
culturally he doesn't like them and
that's the part the American people see
the American people see the culture they
see the president from dislikes the left
on a cultural level but he's willing to
retweet stuff like this that shows
malice with regard to with regard to
Hillary Clinton and they like that
doesn't matter that he's cutting deals
with all of her friends Chuck Schumer's
good friends with Hillary Clinton Nancy
Pelosi is good friends of Hillary
Clinton none of that matters because
again it's cultural Tucker Carlson I
think gets this exactly right with
regard to Trump and it's why Trump has
his finger on a pulse a lot of us don't
follow you know a lot of us are very
interested in data and so we like polls
impose her a great I mean data is better
than no data that being said Tucker
Carlson is right and I think Trump is
right when he says that he Trump grants
a lot more credibility to watching TV
than he does to polls and I think that
there is some I think there is something
to that I think there's something smart
about that
here's Tucker Carlson explaining but I
think more broadly he believes that
television is a pretty clear window into
what people care about he believes that
television producers especially if
highly rated shows understand what the
public is interested in what it fears
what it wants what it loves and so the
TV programming is in some ways a more
accurate reflection in the public mood
than polling that's his view he said it
to me and that's one of the reasons he
watches a lot of television you know and
whether that's true or not is it is it
entirely debatable I think that's
actually sort of true I think it is sort
of true I think that if you're looking I
think it's actually very smart and very
astute for President Trump now it may
just be the Lexx watching TV but it's
also true that what we watch on TV may
be more indicative of what we truly feel
than what we tell pollsters right it's a
different process when watch TV that's
sort of instinctual right you get up you
get up in the morning or you're going to
sleep at night you flip on the TV you
put on what you enjoy
you don't feel judged and then you watch
what you watch and they're measuring the
ratings that's not the same thing as
when a pollster calls you and says what
do you think of X now you have to go
through a conscious process right Daniel
Kahneman talks about this in sort of a
different context the idea that you have
almost two systems in your brain you
have system one which is the fast move
instinctive system and then you have
system two which is the rational system
that sort of overrides the instinctive
system when you kick it in and we tend
to mistake things that we're doing in
system one for things that we're doing
in system two so TV is done through
system one you want to watch something
you flip on the TV you watch whatever
feels good and makes you feel good in
your tummy and then there's system two
which is what you tell pollsters
or somebody ask you a question you
consider you create a rationale you
create a worldview and then you answer
the question what is more accurate and
when you go to vote are you voting with
system water system - I think you're
voting with system one and I think
you're justifying it with system two at
least the vast majority of voters I
think the vast majority of voters have a
gut feeling about a particular candidate
and they decide how they're going to
support that candidate and then they
make up an excuse later I think a lot of
people who are instinctively put off of
President Trump on the left it wasn't
that they hated his policies because he
was closer to their policies than any
Republican candidate of my lifetime no
it was that he himself made them feel
yucky and so they found a rationale for
not voting for him and I think the same
is true on the right with Hillary
Clinton they didn't like Hillary Clinton
an instinctive dislike of her some of it
was political a lot of it was personal
and therefore they came up with a
rationale now the danger of that is that
politics is not actually done in the
system one way politics is not
instinctive politics is where we try to
create policy and policy has to be done
with system two it has to be well
thought out so what happens when you
have a population that's voting based on
system one that's instinctive quick make
the move system in your brain but the
policy that we need is based on system
two what if we're electing people
because we instinctively like them or
dislike them but we actually need to be
doing is engaging system to thinking
about the policy in other words we
should be thinking more about the DREAM
Act and infrastructure and the Paris
Accords than we are about Trump hitting
golf ball and hitting Hillary Clinton in
the back and retweeting it but that's
not how we work that's not how we work
and that's a problem and it also goes to
why culture matters so much now people
say things like well why do you even
want if you don't like the Emmys why do
you even care what the Emmys have to say
the reason people care what the Emmys
have to say is because the enemies are
cultural because when you turn into the
Emmys when you turn when you when you
tune into that channel what you are
doing is you are turning off your
political brain and instinct
way and then you're either going to
react badly to it or react well to it
it's very polarizing in a way that
policy generally isn't I mean it really
is quite fascinating when I talk policy
with folks on the left I disagree with
them radically on policy when we are
both engaged in a conversation about
policy the passion level is much lower
even if we really disagree why because
we're not engaged in the emotional part
of our brain it's not your amygdala
that's firing it's your prefrontal
cortex right you're actually using the
rational part of your brain but when it
comes to who you vote for people get
super passionate like it's so funny I
can talk with the Democrat all day long
about what is the best health care
policy and I can make the case they're
the best health care policy is one that
is based on the notion that health care
is a good not a right and I can't
explain that and they can explain it
right back to me but if if I say listen
Obamacare sucks their immediate response
is not okay let's talk about why
Obamacare socks or whether it's good the
immediate response is you racist jackass
why because system one has kicked in
because culture has kicked in it's why
if you look at the polls fascinating if
you look at the polls Obamacare is
significantly less popular than the
American than the American affordable
care act or whatever they called it the
ACA the Affordable Care Act the
Affordable Care Act always pulled higher
than Obamacare always and it's the exact
same thing why because system one is in
tune when you say Obamacare and system
tune is system two is in tune when you
say Affordable Care Act it removes it
from the from the instinctive system a
little bit a little bit and then once
you get even less instinctive then
people look at the policy and they hate
it again they're really kind of
interesting stuff that's why we tend to
be in the media tend to focus around
flashpoints if you look at the flash
points in American politics they very
rarely have to do with policy and they
usually have to do with something sexy
in the news so for example here's a sexy
thing in the news right now there's
their riots in st. Louis so if you
haven't been watching there are all
these protests in st. Louis regarding
this guy named Jason Stockman Jason
Stockman or Stockley rather Jason
Stockley was a police officer who shot a
guy named Anthony Lamar Smith in 2011
I'm gonna give you all the details and
why this is important in just a second
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at the US ECA so the US
concealed-carry association these are
folks who make sure that you are
protected in case you have to fire your
gun in self-defense very often you'll
have a good guy who uses his gun to
protect family from criminals and then
he's the one who gets arrested because
you got to know what to say to the
police and what not to say to the police
you got to know when you're allowed to
fire in the first place and when you're
not right now the the u.s. CCA is
offering you the 2017 concealed carry
and family defense guide from the u.s.
CCA it's 100% free in it you will learn
how to detect attackers before they see
you how to survive a mass shooting the
safest and most dangerous places to sit
in a restaurant how to responsibly own
and store gun even if you have little
kids which is super important and a
whole lot more it's 164 pages it comes
with a bonus audio version so you can
even listen in your car this life
changing guides 100% free and for a
limited time you will also get a bonus
home defense checklist visit defend my
family now.com defend my family now calm
right now for a hundred percent free
instant access to this concealed carry
and family defense guide again all this
important information you're going to
want to know defend my family now.com
defend my family now calm you oh it's
yourself your gun owner to have all this
information at your fingertips again its
defend my family now calm and the us CCA
it's a group you should definitely
associate with okay so they're basically
riots in st. Louis last night a bunch of
properties broken into burned down I
think is 80 people arrested cop was hit
in the head with a brick pretty brutal
the media have focused on the peaceful
nature of some of the protests but it's
gotten so bad that you to and moved
Sheeran we're both supposed to do
concerts in st. Louis they to cancel
them because the police couldn't defend
the concerts it says a lot like what we
were sort of expecting to happen in
Berkeley and the police showed up and
shut it down in st. Louis they haven't
been able to shut it down and so you've
seen tremendous property destruction why
because of the story about this police
officer named Jason Stockley so in 2011
he killed the guy named Anthony Lamar
Smith I will give you one guess as to
the races of the people involved and why
it's a national issue yes you got it
that's right Jason Stockley the cop is
white
Anthony Lamar Smith is black and and so
basically the case is this Anthony Lamar
Smith was in the middle of a drug deal
and the police were were staking him out
he ran from the police after ramming
them with his vehicle and then he
finally crashed into an SUV
Jason stock we popped out of the car he
ran
over to the car he took out his gun
there's about 15 second gap and then
Jason Stockley shot Anthony Lamar Smith
he claims and Lamar Smith was going for
his gun and that he had warned him not
to and that he shot him and basically
point-blank range people in the
prosecution this guy was prosecuted this
cop suggested that Jason Stockley had
gone in with the intent to murder
Anthony Lamar Smith and killed him and
then planted a gun on him so here is
some of the tape you can judge for
yourself what you think happened here I
here are some of the tape as to as to
what happened so what you'll see I'll
describe it for you if you're listening
and what you'll see is Anthony Lamar
Smith gets in his car the cops pull up
behind him he tries to pull up against
the curb then he realizes he's trapped
he backs into the cop car two cops who
merged what their guns drawn the driver
refuses to stop one of the cops is
holding what looks like an ak-47 and and
which is he's privately an owner of so
it's not as though the cops issue that
so here you see it from a different
angle Anthony Anthony Lamar Smith panics
he backs into the cop car in an attempt
to get out of there and and drives away
so he basically comes very close to
hitting this police officer the police
officers hop back in their car the
police car dash camera video isn't the
best quality but look closely it starts
at the Church's Chicken at Riverview and
Thecla
you can see the timestamp December 20th
2011 a rainy day the officers had
stopped a car in a suspected drug deal
here you can see Officer Jason Stockley
exit the police cruiser in his hand his
own personal weapon an ak-47 a violation
of department policy he raises his hand
to a car coming towards him then points
the a.k at the car as the car drives
away Stockley then pulls his
department-issued weapon and fires it
that he runs back to the police cruiser
and he and the officer driving the cop
car take chase at high rates of speed at
one point they crash into a tree but
continued to pursue the white car a
camera inside the squad car also
capturing that jarring moment you can
hear the officers yelling
prosecutors say at one point Stockley
says quote going to kill this expletive
several minutes later the cruiser
catches up with the white car and rams
the cruiser into it again the moment of
impact seen from inside back on the
dashcam Stockley and his partner are
seen rushing up to the car
moments later is when prosecutors say
Stockley on the right shot five times
striking the cars driver
Anthony Lamar Smith and killing him at
issue in part is exactly what Stockley
does after the shooting okay so what
happens is that you see him go back in
his car dig through his backpack and
then it's unclear what happened so he
was this murder or was this not a murder
so they waived the right to jury trial
and instead they went directly to a
judge which you can do I guess in the in
the state of Missouri and the judge
ruled that he was not guilty doesn't
mean that he was not guilty in the
technical sense in the in the full-on
guilt an innocent sense it means that
he's not guilty according to the letter
of the law because you have to prove it
beyond a reasonable doubt so there are a
couple of things that I think are worth
noting one Anthony Lamar Smith was
involved in a drug deal tried to use his
car to ram police officers ran away from
the police officers at a high rate of
speed endangering people and then
according to the other officers there
you can hear on the tape one of the
other officers shouts gun you can hear
him shout gun and then the officer jason
Stockley shoots anthony Lamar Smith as
far as the idea that he planted a gun in
the car and that there was no actual gun
in the car when I looked at the table I
didn't see a situation which Stockley
actually had the opportunity to plant a
gun without other cops around that means
all the other cops would have had to be
in on it that if the the prosecution
never bothered to call the other cops to
testify that he had planted a gun which
suggests either that everyone missed it
or that Stockley didn't do it so here is
what the judge rules okay the judge
ruled that the that he it had not been
proven that he planted the gun
prosecutors argue that the presence of
stock Lee's DNA on the gun proved that
the gun must have been planted by the
officer the defense countered that
Stockley heard his partner yell gun and
saw the driver's hand on a gun is this
car sped by him stock Lee testified he
does not try his service revolver and
fire until he saw Smith reaching around
inside the vehicle after it was stopped
he said Smith changed his demeanor
suggesting he found the gun so these are
to varying cases Stockley testified
after the shooting he found the gun
tucked down between the seat and the
central console and he rendered the gun
safe by unloading cartridges from the
cylinder and then left the gun and the
cartridges on the passenger seat so the
judge said it's a fact issue that's
central whether Smith had the gun when
he was shot
he said the state's contention the
officer planted the gun was not
supported by the evidence why because a
full sized revolver was too large for
the officer to hide in his pants pocket
and he was not wearing a jacket and if
the gun had been tucked into his belt it
would have been visible on a bystanders
video this is what the judge ruled how
about the outbursts saying that he was
going to kill this guy so the part of
the prosecutor said that this was clear
intense the judge said lots of things
happen when they're in the middle of a
high-speed chase he was saying stuff
okay bottom line is this is a pretty
controversial ruling but is it clear
that this is that this cop murdered the
guy I don't think it's absolutely clear
the cop murdered the guy I don't think
that it's absolutely clear in any way
again the legal standard is proof beyond
a reasonable doubt now the reason that
people have that this is important is
because what you see once again is this
is a cultural issue not a policy issue
on policy we all agree supposedly right
guilt beyond a reasonable doubt and we
all agree the cops should not shoot
innocent people so on a policy level we
all agree with this and we agree that if
there was evidence that this is a racist
shooting the guy should go to jail right
everyone was appalled when there was
that case in South Carolina where Walter
Scott a black eye was shot in the back
by a cop and you can see the cop
planting a gun next to Walter Scott I
believe that he was convicted later but
in any case if there's a hung jury in
any case everyone was appalled if he was
not convicted but this is a major public
policy issue nonetheless even though it
has nothing to do with policy why
because it's cultural because it's
cultural meaning people react by saying
this is indicative of a system that's
racist or they react by saying this is
indicative of a bunch of people who are
always going to say that the system is
racist even without evidence that the
system is racist these cultural issues
shift more votes than anything that
President Trump does on policy policy
does not shift votes in the same way
that culture does and that is because of
the mass media so that's why the Emmys
matter that's why the Emmys matter so
finally at long last I want to get to
the Emmys the Emmys did not get great
ratings last night they did not get
terrific ratings because they're not
very good nobody watches these award
shows anymore
anymore and they still get huge ratings
against other against other TV
but this was a very very low rated Emmys
part of that is because people are
alienated by culture being used to
foment politics part of it is because
all the TV shows that are now being
rewarded our TV shows that a lot of
people have never seen right nobody
watched The Handmaid's Tale I mean in
terms of relative numbers nobody watched
The Handmaid's Tale the shows that were
up for awards were Westworld basically
Handmaid's Tale and and the other one
never was stranger things stranger
things those were the three that were up
for a lot of awards last night
Handmaid's Tale basically swept and it
swept because of politics
so people were not going to tune in to
watch a bad book become a bad TV series
and then get awarded a lot so the
politics made a difference this is the
thing that Hollywood really doesn't
understand if they were a little bit
less overt in their politics they'd
actually be much more effective in
shifting the cultural debate but it's
the culture war that truly matters right
people like Trump because they hate the
Emmys people like from because they hate
Stephen Colbert people like Trump
because they hate what they saw last
night with a bunch of rich puffed up
arrogant elitists who suggests they know
best for the rest of America while
living in their palatial estate soph the
Sunset Boulevard and avoiding their
taxes by banking offshore that's what
people see when they watch the Emmys
that culture war matters a lot more than
where Trump is on the Paris agreements
so long as Trump continues to show scorn
for Hollywood so long as he shows scorn
for leftist cultural institutions he's
gonna get away with whatever policy he
wants to get away with so before I get
to that first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at my Patriot supply
so right now if you are worried about
disaster if you worried about natural
disaster or kim jeong-hoon nuking us or
any of the rest of it you need to go
over to my Patriot supply right now and
make sure that you get your survival
food supply 99 dollars means you get a
hundred and two servings and breakfast
lunches and dinners apparently they
taste like home cooking according to the
folks in the office you can order now at
888 803 1413 888 803 1413 or online at
preparer with Ben calm let's prepare
with Ben's icon again 99 bucks plus free
shipping and that makes sure that you're
not gonna be the person left out when
the grocery closes its stores because
it's out of supplies and nobody can get
there you're gonna be the person who's
smart enough to have spent that
ninety-nine bucks one time stuck in your
class and forgot about it until you need
it again prepare with Ben comm 99 bucks
plus free shipping
8:03 1413 888 803 1413 or prepare with
Ben dot-com gull and check it out okay
so now on to the Emmys so Stephen
Colbert opens up the Emmys and he opens
with this musical number this is
everything this is everything that
Americans like about Trump because they
hate this they hate this from Hollywood
they're sick of being lectured they're
sick of being told that they're wrong
they're sick of being told that they're
rubes they're sick of being told that
there's no such thing as gender they're
sick of being told that gender is a
construct in the mind they're sick of
being told that America is a backwards
place for women and black people they're
sick of being lectured that's what
Hollywood does and when Trump doesn't do
that Trump wins of matter about the
Paris climate Accords because who cares
what does matter is that he hates
Stephen Colbert so here's the beginning
opening musical number
[Music]
well
hi open up let Archer slip inside
[Music]
[Applause]
again the whole thing is a rip on the
news right so the news is terrible the
news is what about people could think
the news in that terrible all right I
mean no like there's like half the
country the things that the news isn't
like it's not the stock markets up right
I mean like people are getting their
jobs back this idea that everything is
garbage and that we're all going to die
I just died
there's not a lot of evidence of that
and then we finally get to the end of
this and I don't know if we can fast
forward to the the graphic where we have
The Handmaid's Tale at the very end of
this little musical number there's a
there's he brings out a bunch of people
to dance for The Handmaid's Tale and
it's a bunch of people in basically
spandex lingerie outfits including a
bunch of dudes right because
transgenderism yay so if you're watching
this at home and you're annoyed by this
and every five seconds there's a there's
a trump joke they're like okay well
listen if I have to choose between
Hollywood and Trump I'll choose belches
Trump the cultural issues matter and
Hollywood needs to understand this
because if they were smart what they
would do is shut up if Hollywood were
smart they would shut up
they really would they would go back to
making entertaining things without a lot
of the political messaging the reason
being they are providing Trump the wall
to bounce up against right Trump is a is
rubber ease of rubber ball bounces up
against things and he bounces up against
Hollywood the rest of the American
people will bounce right with him
they don't like Hollywood we like to
watch it that doesn't mean we like you
right we like to watch floyd mayweather
box too but he's a jerk that doesn't
mean we like you and if we're forced to
choose between floyd mayweather and
anyone else we'll choose anyone else
and if we're forced to choose between
the hollywood morality and anyone else
you'll choose anyone else
and then if Holly let's say Hollywood
shut up for a second let's say that
Hollywood would stop with this with his
nonsense where they feel like they have
to promulgate their politics every five
seconds if Hollywood actually shop about
it Trump wouldn't have anything to moan
about right we'd actually have to focus
in on his policy and then we could get
to some good discussions hopefully we
could move him to the right hopefully
we'd start to get about put care about
policy again as a conservative I want
care about policy not about the Emmys
we'll go through some more of the Emmys
in just a second but for that you're
gonna have some have to subscribe for
$9.99 a month you can subscribe over a
daily wired.com and you can become a
member you get the rest of my show live
we are going to be doing a Q&A tomorrow
on Facebook and if you ask questions on
that
become a subscriber today you can ask
any question under the Sun and I will
answer it for you tomorrow on Facebook
live over it daily where I come $9.99 a
month again and you can get Andrew
Clavin still alive which starts in about
45 minutes here you can get Michael
Moses show which starts at 12:30 Pacific
time all three shows are terrific also
you get the website add banner ad free
which is which is awesome and if you get
the annual subscription get this be very
finest in all beverage ware for $99 a
year you get all of the aforementioned
things plus you get this it cooks it
does hair it makes julienne fries the
leftist here is hot or cold tumblr
actually basically just holds liquid but
it's really great and you will truly
enjoy it and treasure it every day of
your pathetic life leftists here is hot
or cold tumblr make sure you go over and
grab that or go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud subscribe leave us a review
always helps us with our ranking also
final ask over to youtube and subscribe
there because that helps us get the word
out as well we are the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so the opening musical number
wasn't even that the bad part right that
was pretty mild stuff then we got to
Colbert's opening monologue and his
opening monologue
really was pathetic of course there's no
way anyone could possibly watch that
much TV other than the president who
seemed to have a lot of time for that
sort of thing hello sir thank you for
joining us looking forward to the tweets
okay so he made a bunch of Trump jokes
all throughout the evening it never
stopped at any point and then they
brought out at one point Sean Spicer to
mock Trump and to mock himself so so as
ho Spicer was of course played by
Melissa McCarthy who won an Emmy last
night for playing Spicer Alec Baldwin
won an Emmy for playing Trump Kate
McKinnon won an Emmy for playing Hilary
so basically everyone won an Emmy for
playing the part of political people
which just demonstrates the merger
between politics and entertainment right
that we don't talk about the the if we
have to choose between Alec Baldwin and
Donald Trump Donald Trump wins that
battle every time in any case in the
middle of this Sean Spicer is brought
out to make a joke about himself and the
left loses their minds over this Sean do
you know
[Applause]
in Emmys
period both in person and around the
world
okay so again the what's funny about
this listen I think it's funny that he
did this I think that it's funny that
Sean Spicer participated although I've
objected in the past to all of these
politicians participating if we're gonna
do it this is funnier than Obama's just
showing up on random shows or Biden
showing up on random shows because he is
the butt of the joke the left went nuts
over this they went crazy again culture
wars matter more than politics the
culture war matters Sean Spicer comes
out makes a joke about himself he's
mocking himself here right he's mocking
his whole Trump had the biggest audience
in history stick from the inauguration
and what what's the upshot Melissa
McCarthy says she was insulted that he
stole her joke really people on the Left
were insulted that Sean Spicer had been
normalized is these are the same people
who say that Chelsea Manning is a hero
he's the same people say the Chelsea
Manning vice ran a headline today that
she has had Chelsea Manning is the
purest soul on the Internet
what in the hell but these are the
people who say Sean Spicer must never be
normalized Ben Rhodes was national
security adviser under President Obama
and who blatantly lied about the Iran's
yield to the American people for years
he said how could we normalize Sean
Spicer again culture Wars culture wars
and then it gets worse Jane Fonda right
the lady who sat on a Vietcong gun
pointed a North Vietnamese Army gun
pointed in American soldiers and Lily
Tomlin they show up to mock president
Trump into a 9 to 5 routine well yeah
well back in 1980 in that movie we
refuse to be controlled by a sexist
egotistical lying hypocritical bigot
and interment in 2017 we still refuse to
be controlled by a sexist
[Applause]
so much courage Wow you refused to be
frankly he doesn't care about you when
is he trying to control you what'd he do
again this is what Hollywood doesn't
understand their culture war makes this
into a culture war not a political war
and then kate mckinnon gets up and she's
one who played Hillary Clinton at the
end on SNL and you'll recall that she
actually sang hallelujah after Hillary
Clinton lost like a weepy hallelujah
tribute to Hillary Clinton this is so
clear she wanted Hillary to one I guess
she gets up and she thanks Hillary
Clinton I don't remember
Chevy Chase thanking Gerald Ford for
playing Gerald Ford here's here's Kate
McKinnon thank you to fern and Sue's my
la moms thank you jack I love you what
else thank you I was on a very personal
no I wasn't a thank you to Hillary
Clinton for your grace and thank you I
love you
okay thanking Hillary Clinton on a
personal note thank you so much okay
this is why the ratings are low for the
Emmys it's why culture is not only
losing its impact it's losing its voice
it's why it's not even really pushing
Americans to the left anymore because
it's it's so blatant and it's also why
Trump is winning Trump is winning
because of people like this Trump is
winning because so long as it's a
culture war Trump can win but here's the
problem so long as it's a culture war
Republicans can win but conservatives
won't okay the only thing that
conservatives can win on we can use the
culture war to win but then we have to
have a political war or a push for
policy it is not enough to react to Kate
McKinnon it's not enough to react to
Stephen Colbert you then have to
promulgate good policy not move to the
left
okay so just because you hate the Emmys
doesn't mean you should support
president Trump's policies even if you
think that he's right and the Emmys are
wrong okay time for a couple of things I
like done some things that I hate so
things that I like over the weekend
I read a book I'd never read before
actually the book Rebecca by Daphne du
Maurier is a very famous book it was
much more famous probably first half of
the 20th century it's one of the very
early kind of suspense novels and the
movie it won Best Picture in 1940
Laurence Olivier and Joan Fontaine Joan
Fontaine was the sisters with Olivia de
Havilland
so that's why they look so much alike
but the the basic story is that Joan
Fontaine is this
kind of young girl very naive who
marries who marries Laurence Olivier's
character max de winter and max de
winter has this very shadowy past he
lives at this ginormous palatial estate
called Manderley and she is brought in
after the death of his first wife and
marries him and and here is a little bit
of the preview of the movie the movie is
quite good the book is better picture
ever made David O Selznick and Alfred
Hitchcock bring you the Grand Slam Prize
winner that made motion picture history
winner the Academy Award voted by
America's critics as the best picture of
the year and now as a result of a
national poll winning new honours as
audiences throughout the country vote to
see it again
the Selznick studios successor to Gone
with the Wind Rebecca brought to the
screen with all the warmth and emotion
that made millions of readers that claim
Daphne du Maurier's bestseller is the
most exciting love story of our time
okay one of the things that I like about
this previous that nationally reference
is the book right how literate is a
preview when it actually references
specific passages from the book and
shows how closely it used to the book
kind of cool and the adaptation is is is
very good and this is very very early
Laurence Olivier watch him and this and
then watch him in marathon band and then
that's a transformation okay other
things that I like so this this is a
pretty amazing video there's a 66 year
old bodybuilder for I guess his color
blind and his family got him a set of
these very expensive glasses that
allowed him to see color for the very
first time so here he is seeing color
for the first time in his life what a
month
[Applause]
look can you see with our eyes smell
baby and what colors you see those you
see colors now now you have rose-colored
glasses baby work now you see with our
eyes
do you like the balloons
it is pretty amazing how I'm I mean the
technology that we have not to be able
to do these kinds of things it's really
incredible and also there's something
wonderful about the fact that when we
finally experience something wonderful
in life we're almost reduced to children
again you get that you get that feeling
from him it's pretty amazing okay time
for a a quick thing that I hate so clay
Travis but it is a commentator on Fox
Sports and I'd be remiss if I did not
comment on this because it was just
making the entire office laugh
hysterically last week Clay Travis was
was on CNN with Brooke Baldwin and I'm
not sure the name of the other fellow
and he decides to drop his slogan so
apparently Clay Travis is sort of almost
a quasi Howard Stern ask sports figure
like he drops obscenity on his show and
he does this kind of man show vibe
and he dropped one of his slogans and
Brooke Baldwin was not prepared for it
and here's how it went I think that's a
bad move I'm a First Amendment
absolutist I believe in only two things
completely the First Amendment and boobs
and so once they made the decision that
they were not going to say it's related
commentary they couldn't I just want to
make sure I heard you correctly as a
woman hanging anchoring this show did
you say what did you say you believe in
the First Amendment ends be double OBS
boobs to things that have only never let
me were down in this entire country's
history the First Amendment and boobs so
for somebody to come on CNN and to say
something like the only thing I believe
in in a discussion there too and I just
want to make sure I'm hearing you
correctly
z-bo OBS because as a woman I'm I said
boobs
I believe completely in the First
Amendment and in boobs those the only
two things I believe 100% in in this
country and by the way Jamel has he went
straight to that yeah you're absolutely
right I've on national television and
with the female host I say on the radio
because it's true and that's what I do
he said okay so there are a few things
that I think ought to be noted about
this first of all is it appropriate for
Clay Travis to say First Amendment and
boobs on national TV in the middle of a
news show of course it's not appropriate
it's ridiculous okay but the part
that's so absurd is the that's so sexist
how could you say such a thing that's so
sexist and horrifying oh okay it's not
sexist to say men like boobs can this is
devolution evolutionary biology suggests
that men are attracted to secondary
sexual characteristics including breasts
okay if we Minh have trouble with that
then I would suggest that they argue
with a biology textbook there are a lot
of women who work at this office I
showed this to my wife my wife thought
this was the funniest thing she'd ever
seen it's so absurd it's so ridiculous
okay it's just possible is it possible
that we can just say stuff is stupid
without us being deeply offended by it
you can even see in this clip if you go
back to the beginning of the clip you
can see when he first says it Brooke
Baldwin wants to laugh like you can see
she's about to laugh and then she stops
herself and she and she decides that
it's time for her to get offended like
what watch her expression when he first
says it she actually starts to laugh
because she realizes how stupid this
whole thing is and then she realizes
that she has to get offended because
society mandates that we all get
offended about stupid nonsense now so
here's what watch watch Baldwin's face
in this
I just want to make sure you're
anchoring this show right you can see
she wants to laugh right cuz it's
hysterical
he just said boobs in the middle of the
show for no reason okay we're all
five-year-olds that's funny
come on and then is it appropriate again
no it's not appropriate does it lower
the discourse yes but for God's sake I
mean I'm a vulgar ization of the
discourse President Trump is the
president dancing vulgar ization of the
discourse I think that that ship may
have sailed a while ago I can lament the
ship sailing but I'm not gonna pretend
that this is even close to the outer
limit of the ship sailing again CNN
doesn't get to complain about that
either here was their new you here was
their new year's episode 2016 and the
decision all night has been should it be
a tattoo person I mean what are you
thinking I don't want to know
white crazy women really let me ask let
me ask Kathy I think Anderson Pearson is
on live national TV CNN right okay so
we're gonna like whine about national
discourse like CNN take a look in the
mirror again
I can I can say that our discourse has
gone down the toilet and I can also say
that we cannot we don't have to be
deeply offended by Clay Travis leaking
breasts I'm sorry like I'm not gonna
pretend to be deeply if it I think John
pot Horace is lying about this was
exactly correct was this appropriate no
but you sort of have to agree with the
sentiment all right fair enough
we'll be back here tomorrow with all
other things stupid and ridiculous again
that's that's another one of those that
falls under this is why Trump won right
cultural issues people getting offended
over a guy saying he likes boobs
one reason the Trump won ah everything
is stupid apparently there's a story out
today by the way and there's an old
there's an old prophecy that's been
interpreted to say that the world will
end on September 23rd if it does I can't
say that we've lost a lot according to
this particular we'll be back tomorrow
please world try to do better I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]